All right, next up, if you're a writer,
but not quite as prolific as Stephen King,
we might have a new way for you
to get those tipping and typing fingers going.
Thrillist reports there's a new cafe in Japan
designed just for writers.
They got free wifi, plenty of outlets to plug in,
bottomless coffee, but there's one teeny tiny catch,
you are not allowed to leave until you finish writing.
All right?
And you'll be charged $1.20 for every half an hour
that you need extra motivation and you stay there.
Yeah, you can only leave after you've finished
your writing goal for the day,
or when the cafe closes at 7:00, whatever comes first.
(audience laughs)
I will say, I've written a couple books,
you've written a couple books.
It is so difficult to do because you are your own boss.
It's on you to sit down and do it and clock in and finish.
And I'm like the best boss, because I would sit down
and be like, boss, can I have a five minute break?
And I'd be like, yes, you can.
And then I'd go.
(Drew laughs)
So you have to have such structure.
And what you think of this cafe?
I think it's great
because it gives you the structure you need.
When you're artists, you're not used to a 9:00 to 5:00.
And so this gives you a reason to get in there, stay,
and a goal to finish.
Structure and accountability.
Raise of hands
who thinks this idea is good and should come stateside?
I double with you, ma'am.
What is your name?
Caroline.
Caroline, I am so with you with the double hands.
Out of curiosity, why are we enthusiastically
putting up two hands?
I know why for me, but why for you?
Because you need that accountability
to just get stuff done.
I'm with you Ross, I'll do the five minute break.
I'm like, yeah.
Totally.
Sometimes I give myself a 10 minute break too,
you know what I mean, whatever I need.
Why not make some microwave salmon while you're at it?
Well, no.
Caroline.
(audience claps)
It wasn't bad, but I'm not saying that.
Caroline, in true writing fashion and form,
you just paid the earlier story off, thank you very much.
Yeah, thank you for that bookend, thank you.
I love this idea so much
and whatever company is doing this,
please come all over the world.
I just love this.
This a great story to me.
Do it.
Totally.
I want more.
I'm writing a third book.
(Drew gasps)
I know, I know, and I'm like-
Rossy, whoa, we haven't talked about this.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
I'm writing, I'm riding around.
It's a little cookbook.
I'm working on Rossipes, yes.
Ah!
I know.
Oh my god.
I know, is that exciting?
Well...
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
I'm working on it now, is that exciting?
This is...
The world is right with the Rossipes book,
'cause that's been a thing for you for a long time,
it's due.
It's how I lost the 60 pounds,
I kept it off cooking for myself
and really trying to figure out food
and be healthy and be good.
But I will tell you, as inspired as I am to write this book,
I am like, mm, I need a break.
So this is, I need this, I needed to hear this story today.
So thank you, Drew, for bringing this one to me.
I'm glad you liked it.
Thank you.
Oh, and here's one I have for you.
We have a little woodworker in England
making a really big difference.
I love this story.
People reports 12-year-old Gabriel Clark
has always loved woodworking.
And he's a hit on Instagram,
selling handmade cutting boards and bowls
to save up money to buy a bike.
How great is that?
But now he's doing something else amazing.
He's raffling off a special custom bowl
for Ukrainian children.
Yeah.
And proceeds, we love this,
they're gonna go to Save the Children.
And get this, Gabriel has already raised $327,000.
That's incredible.
Woodworking.
(audience applauds)
Wow.
It's just incredible.
He is such a lovely human being.
I think his work is really beautiful.
Beautiful, yeah.
And what a heart and soul in this beautiful human being.
And speaking of supporting Ukraine,
we wanna shout out to our partners at Pluto TV.
Actually, you can catch us on Pluto TV anytime
on The Drew Barrymore Show channel.
And you can check out their Ads for Change campaign
because they're running free ads to get the support
for incredible organizations
doing work on the ground in Ukraine.
Save the Children, World Central Kitchen, UNHCR,
and the International Rescue Committee.
So if you wanna help and you're looking for a place to start
because that's a huge part of it,
is just where do I start?
These are great groups to go and support,
and you can get all the information on our website.
And I always say too, like, $1, $5, that's it.
One of these places, it will make a difference.
Absolutely, yeah.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Pluto, we love you.
(upbeat bright music)